[Music]
reporting Christian Bale's stars in the
first major motion picture about the
Armenian Genocide that took place over
100 years ago
Armenian stars share Kim and Kourtney
Kardashian showed their support posing
on the carpet together
Kim giving us a major 70 cher moment
with her new do ya what goes around
comes around
et spoke with the goddess of pop on the
red carpet in Los Angeles where she
opened up about what the film means to
her no one knows about the genocide so
so it's it's important that people know
share also gave an update on her
mother's health the star recently
dropped out of a Lifetime TV movie to be
there for her my mom is really great you
know my mom's 91 and she's fabulous she
has to worry about just a few things
about getting pneumonia and that's the
thing we worry about the most eat see
also caught up with Christian Bale where
he revealed which celeb he was most
excited to see at the premiere I would
have to be shared with him their thing
that that's for my mother-in-law she's
here she said she was very excited to
see [ __ ]
[Music]